[Music]
my name is a Dukakis I'm from Austria 21
years old
I'm originally from India came here to
the UK in 2004 I came all the way here
for thinking about it just what did you
check the border ticket within one day
and I came here and just it's really
astonishing how outgoing two people are
unfortunately my parents inherited them
death about almost hundred thousand
pounds in debts and ever since I joined
full time work in 2011 it slowly been
trying to pay this off but it's been a
tough journey I was about memory
recently so I'm trying to support to
families as well as pay off the debt and
that's my goal
you know things I haven't told my mom I
just thought that I'm gonna go to a
English course and you know there's much
such thing about like learning English
in two days but I'm gonna tell her
afterwards and I go back and I hopefully
I'm gonna bring them here and we're
gonna attend this crash close together
all I thought was you buy a house refurb
and sell it that was my strategy before
learning about this course but now that
I'm on here that's not the only strategy
there are plenty of others I'm hoping to
get a lot of information as I can I
don't want to put all my eggs in one
basket and I want to learn these
strategies as soon as I watched all the
videos about Samuel deeds and how he
changed all the lives and I was really
amazed about how he did it and I just
wanted to experience it life just finish
the property investors crash course with
Samuel Leeds done two days and
absolutely loved it
yesterday a few doubts that I could
implement a few things and Austria but
after this day I'm sure you can do it
everywhere learnt a lot in terms of
strategies I came in with just one
strategy of rental rent didn't realize
there were five in total that were
introduced at
the crash-course rent rent it's not the
be-all and end-all imma be doing deal
sourcing lease on the options trying to
build service apartment as well into my
portfolio my next step would be to
educate myself to train myself more my
affirmation which I declared in front of
everyone today was to be financially
free by the age of 30 securing and
buying properties to every quarter in
2020 and I will be a successful property
investor but these two days recommend I
recommend it highly to attend this
program because it's just it's just life
changing it I can't wait to work with
Samuel Leeds and the team and next time
I think I'm gonna bring my brother or
your friends and I'm sure they're going
to benefit from that you guys seem
absolutely amazing full of energy really
inspirational and love each of each and
every one of your stories as well thank
you for all information just invaluable
and come back I'll be back
[Music]